this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio
this is the ramsey show where america
hangs out to have a conversation about
your work
your life your relationships and even
your money
i'm dr john dolone joined here by ramsay
personality and best-selling author ken
coleman and we are taking your life are
taking your questions we're not gonna
take your life that would not be great
very gruesome promise
to start off the show we're gonna take
your calls
on work purpose
life relationships money bring it on man
they all kind of tie together
interestingly enough when we lay out
those buckets
you know and you start to depending on
who you are
where you're listening what you're
dealing with today what you've been
dealing with the last week the last
month
you know all those come together john i
know that when when people aren't happy
in their work
they're not happy in their relationships
because it kind of just spills out when
the guy goes home i'll pick on guys
because i'm a dude
but it works for ladies as well we know
from all kinds of studies when you're
not doing meaningful work you feel like
you're stuck you feel like you're not
making any progress
that affects you in the home and you see
that come out as well then and then we
know that you know hey
if you feel like you're stuck
financially
you don't feel like you can make a move
to pursue work that matters deeply to
you if you feel like your whole world is
falling apart relationship wise
money work that becomes secondary that's
right they all
everything works together yeah and i
think we're
feeling a convergence of that right
across the country
as people struggle with work and with
money and with wellness and what does
science mean what politics mean and what
does
my family relationship look like and
should we stay together should we
it's just all yeah landed right in our
lap
right well you know let's just take a
let's just take a a snapshot
when the pandemic hit and of course in
different parts of the country you have
more
opening than than other parts of the
country so you know it really is still
a a circumstance that has been hanging
over
large parts of our nation and certainly
the world
for a year yeah still hanging and here's
what happens
when uncertainty takes hold of us
and i think that's john that's what i
just sense is
since covet came in i just there's
financial uncertainty
professional uncertainty it has
exacerbated and made worse
relationship uncertainty and boy boy we
humans just don't do very well
with uncertainty do we no and i think
most of us do one of two things right we
clamp down yeah
and try to grab everything we can and
and fake certainty
or you just take off running right you
you cover up in the corner and just let
the world spin at you right and it's
finding the
strength and the community and the
relationships and the
the purpose to get in the middle of that
right control those small things and
then let go of the other things right
well we talked about i believe it was uh
oh i'm gonna say two or three
i think it may have been early april
dave ramsey rachel cruz and myself we
did a live event here from our
headquarters
uh and we talked about is called a night
of hope and the message that we drove
home that night was that
you control the controllables focus on
what you can control there's so much in
this world that we cannot control
yeah one of the things i talk a lot
about on the ken coleman show and
helping people live and work on purpose
is what happens when you're in a place
of uncertainty or in a place of
confusion what do you do
because that's that's an overwhelming
feeling the advice that i give is
something that i do in my own life is
that i retreat
to clarity so if i'm in a place where
i'm in financial uncertainty or
professional uncertainty or relationship
uncertainty and i'm realizing right now
there's a lot of things spinning around
me and i can't control it john i start
to go okay
i'm gonna retreat for a second not from
the world i'm not gonna go to a cave and
disappear
but what i am going to do is i'm going
to just step back for a moment whatever
that looks like get some perspective
that's it i call it getting clear just
get clear what well now what can i be
clear on
i'm clear that my wife stacy's counting
on me
my three kids are counting on me yeah
you know whatever if that's if that's
clear get there
right and when i get there i go okay
that means i can't quit no matter how
bad i'm hurting
no matter what's going on in my world
there are other people counting on me my
team's counting on me
right right the ken coleman show has a
team
there are people that are listening
every day they're counting on me to show
up so
for you in those moments i'm just going
to tell you
step back and get clear get clear
financially wait a second what do i have
to do
to just pay the bills the four walls
that's what we teach whatever your
situation relationally how do people get
clear when it feels like their whole
world's spinning on them
yeah i think what i love what you say
that just you got to back up for a
second slow down stop
right get some perspective yeah um
and then sometimes ken like in this
weekend's a great example
um you step back and you just gotta sit
down for a second right so i was telling
you off air
um i hope i can get through this we um
hey man i the world lost a really
remarkable guy
yeah um from a community that i spent
many years in
a guy i've known for a long long time
named mark rogers in abilene texas
um in a senseless unfathomable
car accident with his three lovely
little kids and his extraordinary wife
who's a longtime friend
president of big brothers big sisters a
community leader and get this this is a
story i don't ever tell
it was a dinner we had together years
ago when he started his little podcast
it was the first podcast i ever did
about being well outside inside
relationships what does
wellness look like outside of what we've
been told and
so again my instinct is just like yours
to pull back and say okay they're
counting on me i got to go back in
sometimes when you lose a body when you
lose a light you got to sit down and
just grieve it man
that's right and so it's been a quiet
weekend at the deloney house
sitting there reflecting on um
sometimes life happens at you right and
we're on the show talking a lot about
how much advice we give and you got to
do this go to this
and i think it's it's a um
it's dishonest and and um not truthful
as those are two separate things right
it's just dishonest not to say hey
life comes at us too yeah right well and
so yeah we had a crazy thing
it's not a death with a friend but we
lost our beloved riggins this morning
yeah yeah long time fav and here's the
thing here's what we do
unexpected and i'm dying right now of
course because my wife's at home she's
about right tell the kids
it's like what is going on here what is
happening where does this happen
he was fine last night and then boom and
it's like what happens when you hurt
and and you go i just want to shut down
well you know it's good to chill a
little bit
but but but also and you lean on other
people but then you lean on others you
you come back out you say the sun's
coming up tomorrow
i think that's that's why we're we
didn't plan to share this but we're both
hurting yeah
different ways and it's like you know
what and there's no competition with
grief man i know there is
a lot of people hurting right now a lot
of people hurt and are listening today
you dialed in and you're going okay we
got delony and coleman
but maybe you were supposed to listen
today because you've been through a
season of pain maybe you're in a storm
right now or it just feels like
financial storm or professional storm
relationship store maybe it's all three
can i just tell you
a we know what it feels like we've been
through all three
we're sitting in it right now we're
sitting in it now
yeah it's been a heavy season yeah and i
want to give people permission to both
stop and exhale yeah
take a knee and pray look at other
people and say yeah this just sucks
i wish there was another thing to say
and if you are in a season of sunshine
right now
yeah that's where you walk alongside
somebody else
so here's the deal triple eight eight
two five five two two five that's the
number we'll hurt with you
we'll love on you the sun's coming out
tomorrow i promise triple eight
eight two five five two two five
somebody needs to call we're here
waiting on you this is the ramsay show
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country
or have a better life the army national
guard can help you get there
plus they offer unbelievable financial
benefits
secure your future today visit
nationalguard.com
ramsey to find out more
[Music]
[Applause]
this is the ramsay show i'm john deloney
joined here with best-selling author ken
coleman we're taking your calls on
relationships life whatever's going on
in your world triple eight eight two
five five two two five
triple eight eight two five five two two
five let's go out to
salt lake city utah and talk to sheree
what is going on
oh you know what hey listen glad i have
the chance to talk to you
well i am thrilled to talk to you it's
sherry right
yes yes it's sherry all right okay so
good i immediately
listen you have to know this the call
screener
zack is is sitting in for kelly today
and he got on my headset
and said it is not cherie it is sherry
and i said great and i probably answered
the phone what's up cherie so
i need everyone in america to know that
was my fault not not his
so go for it oh well my question is
well i'm trying to figure out right now
how i get my
16 year old to focus on the future
without driving her absolutely crazy in
the process
oh i've heard this call before so so
let's give us a little bit more uh
detail on what this conversation has
looked like to this point and then i
will
answer that okay well um i'll first tell
you a little bit about
my daughter she's she's 16 she'll be 17
in a couple months
she's very bright she's kind
she's witty she's sarcastic she's
articulate
she's very artistic and
she has big big dreams of doing
something like in
in in hollywood or going to new york and
being a performer
or being a voice actor or being an
artist and
and i know she's so good at all of this
she is she's very good at all of this
but i'm trying to
kind of let her know gently that there
might
be a chance of her having to do
something
while she's getting her foot into the
field
and she doesn't want to hear any of that
like what what's your what's your
suggestion
what do you mean well um my my
suggestions to her is to
to look at some things to what you can
do
for your day job while you are
searching for this while you're um and
while you're improving your
wait a second okay so all right so let's
let's recap sherry because i want you to
hear what you told us
we started off a phone call saying guys
i need your help
uh helping my 16 year old take her
career or her future seriously
i asked for more details then you went
into how bright she is and how talented
she she is and how big her dreams are
so sherry we have a conflict
we don't we don't need to help her get
serious about her future
she's dreaming big that's what i would
want to give as a gift to every parent
of every 16 year old in the world
is a kid who's dreaming big sherry
that's really good news
it's sherry your safety muscle your
parenting gland i'm making these things
up they don't exist john there's
for sure a parenting gland there is it's
on
overdrive right now and you're like
you're basically telling your kid
you need a plan for when your dream
fails that's what you're telling your
daughter and i know you're not
saying that but that's what she's
hearing and the reason she's hearing
that sherry
is because that's what you're projecting
so sherry i love you
i've got three teens sherry i'm not
picking on you
but guess what this kid knows that when
she goes to new york or la
she will have to pay rent and she will
have to come up with food
this kid knows this don't you think yes
or no she does
she does all right so listen so that's
what i'd call a day job
three or four waitressing gigs or
whatever she's got to do but that's not
what you're talking about you're trying
to talk her into
some type of safe career back up like
being
uh you fill in the blank and that is
driving her bananas and she's going mom
i don't want to do that and can i also
just set you free sherry
because you're the one that needs to be
set free
if she goes for those dreams and i hope
she does and i hope you're her number
one cheerleader because if she goes for
it and it doesn't work out for whatever
reason
she'll fall back to something but we
don't we don't encourage our kids if
they play in a sporting event or they
play a musical instrument
hey it's your recital next week do a
good job but have a good excuse in your
back pocket if you don't play well would
you ever dream of telling your kid that
no but that's what you're telling her in
her life
so mom you need to relax and you need to
say how can i support
you and how can i help you and i'll help
you find a job i'll help you find a
place where you can rent i'll help you
find a second or third roommate i just
want to support
your dream anything that that dad and i
can do to help you stay afloat
and stay in the game while you go for it
i'm all in babe
that's what you need to be telling them
and okay
to make your heart feel a little bit
lighter here because you are going to
have to do
your work here 16 year olds or 16
right 16 year old or 16. and so
when a parent goes full in support on
their dreams like ken says
one of two things will happen you will
you will help
fill that rocket with jet fuel and it
will take off or they will realize it's
not as cool when mom thinks it's cool
right yeah the second thing is this
sherry if i look back over the arc of my
career
i've done a lot of schooling and sat in
a lot of classes
if i was to tell you the number one
thing
that i have fallen back on as a senior
administrator at multiple universities
now in this
cartoon job that i have right now i'm
just living this fantasy world
has been my experience in theater
my experience playing with music groups
my experience
in front of other people that will help
her if she if she decides as ken said if
this thing doesn't work out down the
road
you will never the skills you learn
working on a team and
on a film crew the skills you learn
speaking in public
having to come up with learned lines and
project them
and to help learn from all these
different bosses all of those things
will go into her repertoire and she will
take over whatever else job she wants to
do
so you can't lose by encouraging your
daughter to work as a team uh
work on a team as a part of her art work
on her art
what you can do though is man she wants
to go all
in man let her know like matthew matthew
mcconaughey told us
yeah dad said you're gonna go all in
you're going to go all the way
up you're going to work really hard
don't screw this up that's right and
here's the deal sherry
uh you gave me enough evidence to
believe that this is not a delusion
that she does have the talent so what if
she doesn't make it on the la level or
the new york level
who cares maybe god's got a different
place for her but it was pursuing that
path
that led her to her ultimate position if
a kid's delusional parents
yeah shoot them straight let them know
the real real okay but this
this girl's not delusional she's got a
dream and she's got talent to back it up
so
uh i would tell you sherry uh maybe even
an apology might be necessary here not
that you've done anything really wrong
but just say hey babe
i care so deeply about you as your mom
i'm always trying to protect you
uh and the reality is is maybe i tried
to protect you too much
here's how i'm going to support you
that's what i think is is necessary here
and then let her fly
i love can the idea of a parent taking
their kid out
and saying yeah you know what i've been
the brakes here
yes and so starting today yeah i'm going
to be your number one fan
but if we're going to do this we're
going to go all in yeah and you're going
to get really good at this
and you're going to take classes and
you're going to work really hard and and
right and i'm going to be on the front
row of your plays and i'm gonna whatever
that looks like
we're gonna support you we're gonna
support you all in i love that ken
well let me tell you something i deal
with adults who call the ken coleman
show every day that are 35 and 45
and they feel like they don't know what
they do and as i begin to dig and ask
them questions i've had so many
just break into tears men and women and
i'll say
why didn't you pursue it this thing that
we just got out of you
and i can't tell you how many times
they've said because
my mom my dad told me to do something
smart
and safe and smart and safe
is sucking the soul out of people
that's what's happening you were created
to fill a unique role
you are needed you must do it and
parents we got to wake up because if we
try to
push our kids into a safe college and a
safe degree and a safe job we
might be stepping on their very souls
i can tell you that how many i'm fired
up law students
pre-med students medical students
i've talked to and then said i said what
are you doing here they can't stand say
i have to there's the only way it's my
only path i
minister students any amount of students
teachers
you don't like teaching you don't like
kids right my my mom said this is
this is what we do yeah in our family
yeah parents
follow your heart and not recklessly not
idiotically
and as kids said you'll know i've met
with a lot of students they're like hey
i'm supposed to be a singer and then you
hear them sing and you're like
no you're not you're not yeah but if
your kids got the talent get behind them
support them the world has plenty of
people that will tell them that they're
not good enough
yep let you be their cheerleader get in
their corner this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
this is the ramsey show i'm john dolone
joined here with ken coleman and one of
my favorite things about the ramsey show
standing here in the lobby on the debt
free stage
is bryce what's going on brother not
much man
i just want to say i'm grateful for
being here so uh thank you guys for what
you do
well we are glad you're here man so
where are you from i'm originally from
illinois i just moved to houston texas
two years ago all right that's my home
that explains the boots the boots look
good those are debt free boots by the
way
exactly right you've got a you've got a
debt-free stance about you all right man
so what'd you pay off
twenty eight thousand seven hundred
fifty dollars of student debt
wow twenty eight thousand and fifty
dollars so no other debt
no other debt just student loans what's
your degree in man uh
occupational safety and health
occupational safety helps that would
take you to houston yes sir
all right man so how long did that take
you six months
wow oh dude you're not screwing around
uh
luckily i got a good job coming out of
college and uh threw everything i had at
it
what's your range of income 75 000 to 82
000. that'll boy and that's that's
during a
i've heard rumors that it was kind of a
messy year or two yeah
yeah so what happened
six months ago that you said enough man
well
i mean i came out of school uh i
transferred into my
uh my university debt-free so um
once i got into my university i then
graduated and i didn't want to have that
debt
uh lingering so hold on you transferred
into university debt free and you
thought
let's rock and roll not a mistake or
kind of a mistake uh to get back
into debt was it party money or was it
for uh
there you go yeah a little bit a little
bit
you guys can't hear the lobbies yeah i
can't hear them it's booing
a little bit yeah they were like giving
them some grief they're enjoying it out
there that's right
so one guy one guy's got popcorn out
there he's enjoying that line so much
so you decided hey i've got one year
left two years left
let's live it up a little bit you lived
really nice in in a
really nice apartment no not at all oh
so what'd you spend the money on
just stupid stuff man atta boy yeah
all right so then you get this new job
then what
so i got the new job uh
just from there i just started throwing
the money at the debt and i wanted to
get rid of it i wanted to be able
to have a life that i could enjoy
because
you know moving down there i had less
than a thousand dollars all my family's
backing up in illinois
so really i didn't know anybody and uh
just wanted to make sure i got that debt
out of the way so i could live the life
i wanted to have
so do people give you grief for making
that kind of money
driving the same car and the not going
out and hanging out
oh yeah all my co-workers uh pretty much
everybody that i i know gives me that
the grief i uh
purchased the car but for about twelve
hundred dollars
uh luckily i'm mechanically inclined so
they all told me you know oh it's
it's gonna go down in a few months but i
fixed it
and now it's look at you a little over
40 000 miles
down the drain now did you did you ever
question this decision
once you started getting that negative
peer pressure did you start going oh man
do i really want to do this or were you
a rock
oh every step of the way i mean i had
that lingering thought i was like well i
could be doing that and then
i mean i got my student loan paid off in
six months so yeah how do you like them
apples right
yeah okay so who got you on this program
so actually
back in high school my grandma grandpa
bought me a book
and it was you know talking about what
not to do in college so i went through
college without
any credit cards still don't have a
credit card so uh
really they went through financial peace
university and stuff
got me hooked on it and then once i went
to college
uh i had a three-hour drive back and
forth from home and really
the dave ramsey podcast kept me awake
going back and forth from home so
oh that's good it puts a lot of people
to sleep so i'm glad it kept you awake
man wow you know dave's not here today
john's feeling very brave with the jokes
uh so big fella i got a question for you
what what what does it feel like
now on the other side of this intense
six-month run
uh just a huge sigh of relief honestly
um
in the grand scheme of things it wasn't
that much debt um
for me it was a lot i'm sure i listen to
the show and i hear
you know some people talk about how
massive of debt they have and you know
i'm grateful that uh i got to you guys
pretty
pretty soon so so i don't want you to
ever get in the comparison game starting
now
debt is debt and twenty thousand dollars
can feel like 2.8 million right
it and it weighs you down and it keeps
you it keeps you from moving
through life the way you want to who's
your uh biggest cheerleader
who walked alongside you in this crazy
six months uh for sure my parents
and then my grandparents as well okay
what was it like calling grim
grandma and grandpa and letting them
know hey guys i transferred debt-free i
had no credit cards
and then i decided you know what i'm a
handsome guy i need about 28 thousand
dollars of just
play money yeah they they weren't super
excited about that
but uh no i'm kidding i'm kidding they
were super
stoked they were happy for you so what
now what are you gonna do now
so i'm gonna go uh go on some vacations
okay
that's why uh i decided to fly here
because i wasn't turning down
the chance to come here and talk to you
guys that's awesome that's so cool
what's the key
people are listening right now other
young fellows young ladies out there
they're they're in the prime they're out
there experiencing the world they can do
a lot of fun things
but if they do what you did they're
gonna have to choose a sacrifice
big time and it's not so fun what would
you tell them the key is to get through
all of that
just be weird don't listen to what
everybody else does
uh pick your own path and uh
then you can be debt free and
stress-free very cool love it who you
got with you yeah i see a pair of shiny
white boots
uh behind the camera this is my
girlfriend mackenzie grimsley
she flew she's just moved into houston
with me okay
she flew in with me as well so wait a
minute you're telling me you can be on a
budget and pay off debt and have
a beautiful person chase you across the
country
yep i thought that was mutually
exclusive nope
not now any big plans you'd like to
announce here on the dave ramsey show
live excuse me the ramsey show look at
me putting him under pressure i thought
we could have a moment here i listen i'm
not trying to put pressure on you i'm
just selfishly trying to create a great
broadcasting moment
yeah listen this is all about us too if
you were to actually make this happen
right now
this clip lives forever yeah him and i
benefit i don't know who's more
embarrassed her or him
it might be a tie this is fantastic you
know i thought about it but uh my best
man kind of forgot the ring
oh i love how you're deflecting that and
blaming it on other people well played
man
all right well bryce from houston texas
paid off 28 thousand dollars
in not one year but six months during
the middle of a pandemic making 75 to 82
thousand dollars and he kept his
girlfriend yup
rattle it off for us brother
i'm debt-free
there it is oh
that was fun he was sitting there going
boy this this
this is really happening did you see
that that was the pause he looks up
and he's going wow i actually did this
that's the reddest face i've seen on
that stage i think
well we did we did put a little extra
pressure on him because we can
you know and we'll apologize to him on
that absolutely no but you had it shot
man
he's gonna do it like in a in a
restaurant in houston now later on not
near as cool we tried to help you out
she actually emailed us before the show
and said to pressure you and
no that's not true it's not oh my
goodness
can you imagine well i'll tell you
i didn't make anywhere near that when i
graduated college oh yeah this young man
is got a bright future
i got out yeah and then i ended up in
more debt making
good money yeah he's making between 75
and 82. let's say he's at that 82 right
now
he's in great shape now he's moving he's
just moving along through the baby steps
before he knows it
he's a net worth millionaire uh and his
whole life is different yeah
his whole perspective i love that he's
taking trips i would say to you young
man when you take
trips uh use that time not just to to
recuperate and kind of
restore yourself from a time of great
sacrifice
reward yourself but also think big i
mean what could you do
if you have no debt what could you fund
now that you don't have
the tremendous burden that so many young
people your age have i got to tell you
as a guy who's always preaching live and
work on purpose you know now
there's really nothing holding you back
from what your dream is what's your
contribution
that you're going to give to the world
through your work and through your
relationships so
man we're really proud of you thanks for
sharing that uh debt free screen with us
it is our
favorite part of the show and always
will be because it's the moment
when men and women step triumphantly cro
across a very impressive finish line and
it's all about freedom so
thank you sir really good stuff bryce
and you don't know what this feels like
yet
but take it from two guys with kids your
kids will never know
yeah the stressed out dad who doesn't is
worried about losing the house
because you did stuff on your own good
for you it's legacy changing stuff man
good for you bryce
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
triple eight eight two five five two two
five this is the ramsey show i'm john
delony with
ken coleman and we are taking your calls
on work and purpose and relationships
and your money
let's go to zach in cincinnati ohio zack
what's going on
uh i'm not much man just uh working on
living the dream i guess there we go
so what's up man how can we help so
few months back i bought a 30
000 car um
basically just because i needed
something that was good for the winter i
had a real dry sports car
so i bought a four wheel drive 2017 jeep
uh 29 000 in debt i work full time and
make about 13
an hour i'm a full-time student but my
school is paid for
um so my mom kind of said hey let's buy
this
car and then you can just use the ramsey
plan to pay it off but after watching
more of the content on youtube
uh yeah that's not the rating plan yeah
we are not
fans just like we should clear this up
for everybody parents included
we are not for you buying a car and then
using the debt snowball to get out of it
it's not a it's not a one-two punch it's
kind of hey
you know what high-five your mom well
played on her part yeah nice move mom
yeah so what's your question i guess my
question is
i looked up the kelly blue book value uh
it's like between 25 and 27
i owe 28 currently should i
at this point just sell pay down to the
value and then sell the car
or because i can do that at the moment
um or should i
just try to take this that snowball
approach to it give us the numbers when
you say you can pay something on it
what's that number
so i can put probably about twenty eight
hundred dollars on it this month
to get me down into the range of the
kelly blue book value
i make sixteen hundred dollars a month
roughly uh i could make more
and work more and get another job over
the summer to help pay the car
off yeah but like just off of what i'm
going off of now i make
yeah well so it's kind of a both end so
here's what i want you to do
uh you you need to uh put the 2800 on it
uh but you need to be working extra
hours you can do that now your young guy
just go go go go let's pay more of this
down
uh so that when you sell it you've got
something you you've got something to
play with so you can buy a car that's
you know four or five thousand dollar
car that will easily take care of you
yeah and and zach i'd i'd even go one
step further i would
see if you could list this thing
tomorrow and see what you can get for it
and if you can end up um i don't mind
you taking out a small loan to
pay the gap off and taking that 200
bucks and going to
buy yourself a car with cash a beater
car and then working really hard to get
that
small loan paid off because you're going
to go from i know it sounds weird for
somebody on dave ramsey i'll tell you
take it alone but you're going to go
from
owing what 25 000 on a depreciating
asset to owing
let's say you get 26 for it there's a
sucker somewhere and you're gonna owe
that two thousand dollars you're gonna
take that 2800 you're gonna pay that two
thousand dollar gap and then you're
gonna save up a little bit of money and
then buy yourself a car that's gonna get
you to and fro
you got no business man being in a 25
000 car
making yeah um 1600 the only thing i'd
say is if you do john's plan you got to
have a car
or you're gonna have to plan to
somebody's you're borrowing a car so if
you need transportation
uh there's a couple ways to get this
thing knocked out but knock it out very
very quickly
this is not something i want to take my
time with this is let's
let's knock it out quickly get yourself
a much cheaper car and then start
building back
yeah i had i had five thousand dollars
saved up on it and truth be told i
thought it was a bad idea but
i seen the jeep and then got kind of
like hey listen don't beat yourself up
we've all had that happen
at some point in our lives where you
know the car looks really shiny and
starts to whisper buy me buy me hey man
you know
and and if you get out of life with a
your stupid taxes
four dollars three dollars a year come
on man decision tax is
three four thousand bucks man you've won
our
dave talks about his his stupid taxes
had
multiple commas in it so you're good man
you're good learn this lesson now as a
young man
and then move on man you're never gonna
do this again and you've got a bright
future ahead of you
good for you hey ken you
have spent the last year during a
chaotic season
walking with people who have been
furloughed been lost their job
had this base their cage rattled enough
to go
i've been living somebody else's life
for so long
and i'm not doing anymore because life's
too short i don't know what's coming our
way
i'm gonna make some changes here you've
been taking
hundreds of calls throughout this year
so much so that
the world is essentially demanded hey
let's do something big yeah
walk me through what you're doing man
yeah well so we're going to bring back a
very popular ramsey solutions event that
we did last year i believe it was june
of last year as people were really
beginning to feel the shock
in the job market is it contracted so
quickly and so we're bringing back the
get hired event it was a wild success
last year we're gonna bring it back
it's the first three stages of my seven
stages to meaningful work on the ken
coleman show if you're new to
to me as a part of the ramsey solutions
personality group and of course our show
is a part of the ramsey network
so i'm helping people figure out what
they were created to do in their work
and then making that
uh meaningful work a reality and so
there's three stages that start off our
seven stages get clear
get qualified get connected and so we're
really gonna hone in on those three
stages
at this get hired event it is a live
stream event we're gonna actually have a
live
crowd john here in nashville stop the
match yeah
down down in our gorgeous gorgeous uh uh
atrium area
and we're gonna live stream it around
the globe it's april the 27th
and i would point out for some of you
financially you're in a place where you
can afford it you're looking for a trip
you just want to get out of your state
we're doing live events we're healthy
here in nashville
so if you want to come it'd be a great
great trip and so it's limited live
seats uh but most of the ticketing just
starts at twenty dollars we have
multiple
tiers but just your basic ticket to
watch it anywhere in the world
twenty dollars you can purchase the
tickets at daveramsey.com
events april 27th april 27th put it on
your calendar right now
april the 27th is our get hired event
and it starts at 8 eastern 7 central
time
tickets start at just 20 dave ramsey.com
slash events who is it for it's for
people that are starting out we got a
lot of college kids john gonna hit the
world in may june
it's for people that are looking to
switch switch careers
it's people that are saying hey i got
furloughed or i got laid off
and i've been doing two or three
part-time jobs i'm ready to get back in
the full-time
uh situation and get that shovel bigger
so i can get out of debt
so if you need to get hired you just let
that sit for a second i want to get
hired
somewhere else then this event is for
you it's april 27th 80's from 7
central tickets daveramsey.com events
and i would say
if you want to come to nashville this
would be a great fun trip we're going to
do some really special stuff
for the live crowd be a couple hundred
people very limited very safe yeah very
healthy
i think there's a fourth person i'd like
to throw in there that i've heard
through my show i always like a fourth
person who could buy a ticket so here's
the thing
i bet there are untold people
you know we talk about the last year has
been really people
living in and out of a crisis yep
business owners small business owners
big business owners we had the election
we've had the market roller coasters
we've had just chaos on top of chaos
sometimes in chaos you find out
who your leadership really is they
emerge
right and you may have been distant from
your leadership you may have been close
to them
and in good times everybody's smiling
right
and then all of a sudden something
catches fire and you find out how people
respond
in chaos you find out how people respond
when things get hard
and suddenly you realize my values don't
align here anymore
or i don't want to be a part of this
thing going forward
but you've put your time in you put your
years in you've on a career track
and you don't know what to do i love
that yeah and
just being able to to back up like we
talked about the very beginning of this
hour
you gotta back way up slow down and
start with
part one of your plan gotta get clear
man well it's a great point cause a lot
of those folks that john just described
what you're feeling is wait a second i'm
too successful i've got too much money
invested in my 401k here i've been here
so long i've been very successful in
this industry and here's two things that
happened number one you feel like you
can't move on
oh ken i'm in my late 40s i'm in my
early to mid 50s ken no one's going to
want to hire me
that's that golden handcuff for you
young people that are watching and
listening to the show today
that's where that comes from i'm making
too much money i'm too successful
successful to change and that's simply
not true certainly not with the economy
booming the way that it is now and
technology becoming easier and easier
and easier to get into
i mean we have people ought to call the
ken coleman show john mid 50s
and they'll partner with bethel tech one
of our partners
here at ramsey and the ken coleman show
and within
nine months for less than 15 grand they
can start in technology for 75 000.
that's just one example
so it's not too late it's not join us at
the get hired event it's going to be fun
all right that's uh first hours in the
books want to thank zach and
james running the boards and the phones
ken
thank you so much always fun to hang out
we'll see you soon this is the ramsay
[Music]
show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of
ramsay advice in their life let them
know about the ramsey call of the day
podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day
podcast wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio
this is the ramsey show where america
hangs out to have a conversation
about your life your work your
relationships your purpose
and your money i am john doloni joined
here by best-selling author and good man
ken coleman and we are taking your calls
on just about everything
yeah triple eight eight two five five
two two five it's triple eight eight two
five
five two two five we have a packed
lobby out there so excited good to see
everybody smiling faces
beautiful folks out there spring
breakers yeah oh
yeah i think i don't know i just oh i
got to tell you those don't look like
spring breakers to me they all look
really young
these people look very wealthy because
they have financial peace these people
look determined because they're on their
baby steps
these people look happy because they're
indoors i think that's aegis
drinking good coffee having great baked
goods as you get here
uh at ramsey solutions i don't think we
mentioned that enough james
that even though we're in our new
building uh you get the same
incredible delectables uh your cold
beverages your hot beverage i should
point out non-alcoholic
you would yeah well it's just fun i
don't want people coming for a kegger
and understanding it's a coffee shop
you know but uh we've got we kind of
have a line of high school kids
has everybody had some baked goods today
they're mostly shaking their head yeah
that's
fantastic yeah a couple of ladies are
like no no i'm watching my figure
nope that guy right there is thank you
very much but hey we support you man
all right triple eight eight two five
five two two five let's go to josh in
johnson city
josh what's going on man hey how you
doing john how you doing ken
uh we're living the dream what's up all
right
so my question for you guys is i'm
working on starting up
my uh my own personal business and i've
been doing a ton of research lately i'm
trying to figure out uh
what the best what the best things uh
that i gotta do are
and uh one of them is business entities
i'm looking into sole proprietor
and um llc more specifically those two
and i'm just trying to figure out if you
guys could answer or even like point me
in the right direction
what i need to be looking forward to
specifically because i
don't really want to lose my assets
because somebody decides to sue me for
a random reason right what's the
business uh
funny enough uh because of ramsey's
solution thanks guys i'm looking to be
a financial coach yeah you don't need to
have an llc for protection on that uh
you know again it's not going to hurt
you if you wanted to choose an llc it's
not like it's going to have this huge
differentiation
for you from a tax standpoint
and being a sole proprietor so if it
were me personally
having owned my own company before i
came to ramsey uh
we we were sole proprietors um because
of the nature of the business we were in
it wasn't this litigious type
business and as a financial coach i
think you're okay but
um if you want to do the llc to make you
sleep better at night
that's fine too and that's a pretty low
lift very low lift
there's not like this major choice you
have do you understand what i'm saying
it's not like
you may have a little bit more paperwork
to fill out from the llc so as far as
doing the research there
um you know you just do your research on
what you're setting up and the filing
and all that kind of stuff just
but it's really not that huge of a
difference i don't think you have to do
an llc
here but if you would like to fine
you know it's as simple as calling a
local attorney and getting it set up
yeah yeah not a major decision is my
point
do do the homework talk to an attorney
on this uh make sure you have all the
nuances and understand it all
but this is not a bad decision one way
or the other all right let's go to eric
in
jackson mississippi eric what's going on
how you doing ken man i am living the
dream how are you sir
i'm doing good how are you guys doing
today we are doing outstanding look
what's up man how can we help okay look
the question i have i have a dilemma i
um i have about six thousand dollars
that i have
uh saved up and i need to fed towards my
debt
i only have two debts which are about
five thousand dollars in credit cards
and i have an auto loan which i owe
about thirty nine hundred dollars on
i was wanting to know which way do you
think i should go with the 6 000
of you know as far as going to pay these
debts off
that's a great question dude
congratulations you're almost there
brother that's awesome
so you got 6 000 bucks hey man
hey and you know what you get to the
finish line and you turn that corner of
that marathon and you just see that
that finish line it's just one mile
right and you start stumbling and
smiling and drooling you're almost there
man
all right so just keep following the
baby steps
so you said you've got a five thousand
dollar credit card and uh would you say
3900
auto loan yes sir yes sir all right so
before today is over i want you to take
3 900 bucks of that
6 000 and that car is gonna be yours and
nobody else's
today okay yes sir and then you're gonna
take the rest of that
dump that over the credit card keep it
make sure you got
that thousand bucks in your emergency
fund um and then you are gonna just
scratch and call and get the rest of
that credit card done and then you're
gonna call this show back
or you're gonna come down here and visit
us and we're gonna do your debt-free
screen right here in the lobby
is that cool yes sir you got that eric
so here's the deal
you got 6k you got 6 000 in savings
you're gonna you're gonna keep a
thousand dollars in the savings all
right
and then five goes to the 3 900 right
you're gonna wipe that out that leaves
1100
all right i got my shoes off so i can
count that high okay and so we take the
1100
and you put it into the 5 000 on the
credit card and now
we are starting to cook now you got 3
900 left
and then you're attacking this thing man
how long you been on this journey eric
to be honest man about a year and a half
now you are so close
how much you paid off watching you guys
man i had about 33 000 all together
eric now this might be worth a trip to
nashville to stand on that debt-free
stage over there
and uh we won't know who's hosting that
day but you need to do that you need to
consider that
man look that that's that's really a
part of the journey man
really a big piece that i think i'll be
missing man i think so
jackson mississippi's not that far away
yeah you can drive here
we can't wait but not at all not at all
all right so by the end of today you own
that car outright and then you are
just throwing everything you've got left
today i mean let's put him on hold and
start start writing checks dirk
exactly don't even hang out what are we
waiting on there's there's 47 minutes in
this hour
it needs to be before the hour is out i
love it pay this stuff
off that's exciting he's going to have 3
900 left
he's gonna knock that out fast that's
huge i remember
that last little yeah little
construction paper chain we had left
this is how romantic i am ken when my
wife and i were going through this we
had
six figures in our debt and we created
one of those
construction paper chains and i'm so
romantic i hung it in our lit in our
bedroom
i never wanted to to not see it
and man did not make for great bedroom
decor but it made for every morning you
wake up and you see it and every night
you go to sleep and you see it it made
me a little bit
nuts but i remember that last chain and
just sat there and stared at us because
it was a big one right but
finally getting that thing done it's fun
did you did you
rip it off the wall i mean was there was
that what was the
no it was a little bit dramatic i this
is gonna shock the listeners i could be
a little bit melted that's why i
set you up on this one no it was a slow
pulled the tack out gently
my heart beat it felt a little hallmarky
my wife rolled her eyes and just walked
in
nothing about that was romantic or
hallmark you kept saying romantic or
romantic and it just felt like crafts
arts and crafts elementary school they
have the change the music swell
it no music actually did swell but in my
heart it did and it just came louder and
there was no confetti or nothing my wife
said cool hey make sure when you go to
the store get somebody
it was kind of lovely yeah i was excited
that's the kind of free advice you get
on this show baby this is the ramsey
show
[Music]
cliff and i joined christian healthcare
ministries because we really liked the
concept of
christians sharing each other's burdens
and we really experienced that firsthand
when cliff
was diagnosed with heart disease it was
just
such a relief to know that financial
burden
was going to be taken care of chm is the
original and longest serving health cost
sharing ministry
get started today and check us out at
chministries.org
backslash budget
[Music]
triple eight eight two five five two two
five it's triple eight eight two five
five two
five i'm john dolone this is ken coleman
on the ramsay show taking your calls
about work
and life and money let's go to regina in
nashville right down the street
what's up regina hi uh
ken hi john thanks for taking my call
i'm doing good today just
trying to get my act together and all
right work regina we're all trying to
get our act together thanks for calling
what's up
well um we moved uh to the area
back in october and i've been trying to
find some work uh office work is what
i've you know done
like for the last 20 some years i've got
my eye set on becoming a loan
signing agent in the future and you know
have to
do some training and take the exams and
stuff for that but
i really would like to get some type of
an office job
soon sooner than later because you know
the money is running out
and i i don't really want to go
do retail or any place like that where i
have to work on weekends because
you know i want some time to spend with
my husband
on the weekends but i haven't really
been having a whole lot of luck
as far as you know office work that's
available
um i want to stay out of the health
field
um just because of you know the corona
situation that's going on
so just wondering what's the way to
to boost you know where
the progress that i'm not making sure i
just
i don't feel like i make a headway okay
so let me ask you what you've done so
far let's look at your process for
getting hired
so have you just been submitting resumes
or just kind of cold without any kind of
contacts at companies just submitting
those online or however that works
answer that for me as well as have you
gotten any interviews and what's that
process been like
uh okay so um i have been doing some
uh you know cold cold sending
resumes out to companies i've worked
with a couple of
uh trump agencies to see if they could
get me some work but
you know with the holidays and whatnot
it was kind of slow and things are just
starting to pick up
so i have had a few nibbles um last week
i went
out on two interviews and i had a phone
interview
and uh the the one interview uh
may look uh prosperous they they did
offer to bring me on board for a day to
take a look at you know um what the
process is
uh in the office as far as and what did
you say
did you say yes i'll be there oh you
betcha
okay when is that um that's going to be
this this week
okay great okay so here's the thing you
just need a
you need encouragement and and i'm going
to give you that but you also need some
better tactics okay
now the reality is is that you're new to
nashville you moved here in october so
you don't have a
ton of friends and i understand we've
been in a covid kind of a situation
where you know socializing is a little
bit different
but the reality is is that you need to
be a little bit more open to
when you say office work i think you
need to expand the search
you're looking for any type of
administrative type work that you can do
where you can just be in there
and you're helping out and the good news
is you got a couple of interviews
you uh you're starting to see some
traction i would continue with the temp
agency as well because many times temp
agencies are the key
to getting in a place and getting that
full-time employment so i would i would
here's my point
i want lots of buckets out in front of
you okay and this is i'm in this bucket
i'm going the temp agency
in this bucket over here uh i've got a
couple of companies that i've heard good
things about
and i want to find a way to make some
connections over there even though i've
not been in nashville very long
and that's the idea of thinking about
your connections now here's what we know
john
from sociology research and that is that
most people get their jobs
through acquaintances not through
close friends and family so i get this
call a lot on the ken coleman show
people say ken
here's the problem i don't know anybody
and that's never true right well let me
just shock everybody listening and
watching today
even if you think you don't know a whole
lot of people you know everybody you
need to know
to get where you want to go so what has
to happen here is
there's an old game i don't know if many
young people have heard of the seven
degrees of kevin bacon that people would
play and they basically throw out kevin
bacon and let's say denzel washington
and you basically had to connect the two
you know through
seven connections or less right from
movies that they both started and
sometimes they may start in the same
movie but the idea is is like
you just play this connection game and
that's what has to happen here because
acquaintances john not lifelong friends
people i've known forever
and so if if we need more acquaintances
then guess what we need to do
i'm gonna let this sit john cause i'm
about ready to drop some depth
if we need more acquaintances they keep
moving the camera light on me downstairs
i'm like trying to find the camera like
here if we need more acquaintances guess
what we need to do
get acquainted stop it ken
i think i'm taking over from there
because cars are screeching across
america i just blew my own mind i need
to sit back and take a sip of water
so what you're telling me again the
presses have all stopped
that i need to get out and communicate
with other people yeah start getting
acquainted saying hey i'm looking for an
administrative type job i'm looking for
a job in an office over here
but i don't think i could you know it
works just
hold submit my resume to a million
people sure you can
but guess what it's like playing the job
lottery
go look up the odds for winning the
lottery yeah people are getting more and
more inundated and i shared this article
on the ken coleman show last week
more and more john people are being
interviewed in the first
initial two or three interviews by
artificial intelligence
because yeah because hr can't keep up
with all the demands so they've got
these
key words they're looking for and
they're asking you questions and and
you're looking into a screen and they're
analyzing your answers your facial
recognition
true stories happening all over the
place wow yeah
so the human connection is really really
important and again
you can't say well i don't know anybody
regina because you do
and you need to know more people so
that's first thing second thing is
go to my website kencoleman.com we've
got three
free they're all free get hired guides
and you need to redo your resume we've
got a wonderful template tell you how to
do it hundreds of thousands of people
have done it it makes you stand out
because i flip it upside down and you
can go check that out then you got the
how to win the interview
and then third how to follow up those
three guides
if you do it the way i tell you to do it
and you make some more acquaintances
and tell more people what kind of work
you're looking for this is a very hot
job market in nashville you can get
hired right now
so what do you tell somebody and i've
had this conversation i can't even tell
you how many times i had this
conversation
particularly with graduating students
yeah
whose acquaintance network
doesn't quote unquote know of anything
right now right at some point they begin
getting the message
hey we wouldn't hire you right right
what do you tell somebody who's who's
getting that negative feedback
right either explicitly or
not explicitly well more and more in in
our world we don't get much feedback
right
so i want to correct your analogy or
your metaphor so that people understand
you don't get a lot of feedback these
days uh even if you get to the interview
level
right they'll say you know what we chose
another candidate now there's a couple
reasons
so litigious man everyone's very
litigious second reason is we as humans
don't like to be confrontational that
feels like a confrontation just telling
somebody we chose somebody else
and and then the third reason is is that
they've got so many candidates
that they can't really give you a
detailed description in their mind they
can't i feel like we should
phil we owe it to people but the reality
is we run on an efficiency table in this
world so
because of that um if you have real
feedback
well then we want to look at it right am
i you know it gets back to what i teach
let's get clear stage one of my seven
stages to meaningful work is get clear
on on what you do best talent hard
skills and soft skills
get clear on the work you love to do
passion i get excited when i think about
this work
i get excited when i'm in the middle of
this work and then finally get clear
about what results that you want to put
into this world
results you want to accomplish through
your work
that's meaningful work because it's on
purpose i use what i do best john
to do work i love to accomplish results
that matter to me
so we got to take that negative feedback
and go
oh where am i off so that's what i'm
getting at i
if you find yourself in a loop
ask somebody yeah get real feet go hey
do i have the talents
on me do i have to do this on me yes and
if somebody
has the courage and the vulnerability
and they are brave and says
hey can we just talk is this on me tell
them the truth
yep tell them the truth that's right
it's so hard to ask for real feedback
right
it's hard and that sometimes somebody
can't get clear on their own and they
need other people to
help them right need a mirror do we see
ourselves the way the world seizes
many don't it's great that's a gift to
be asking to
to be asked be honest and gentle
john look what i see over there coming
up next a debt free scream
live from the ramsey solutions lobby
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
on the debt-free stage sutton and
madison usually
when a couple is standing on the
debt-free stage that means they've got
remarkable news to share with us
so what's the story we do what's the
story we paid off
forty four thousand two hundred dollars
forty four thousand
two hundred dollars how long did it take
you nine months and five days whoa
nine months in five days not that we're
counting
what was your range of income during
this time started around 43
000 ended up around 54 000. oh i'm
always curious with this one
uh what did you do to raise the income
lots of side jobs
madison got a job working at his
college's bookstore
part-time i got a job at a production
company doing a 24-7
sports talk show so i had to get up at
like 4 a.m and go do that before work
my man now are you in broadcasting or is
this just something you've always kind
of wanted to do and you just jumped into
it to make some extra time i've always
loved broadcasting i'm actually a
worship pastor at a church
are you really so i had a few of the
skills and obviously with kovid
had to learn how to do broadcast with
pretty much everything yeah hey i
started out doing
uh sports radio oh really yeah it's
awesome so i've got a little special
place in my heart
look at this shining example right here
right that's right it's perfect okay so
43 to 54 you said yeah so
that's a lot of money to pay off in nine
months did you sell something or someone
what
how did you do this we both had a little
bit of savings when we got married
and we had a wedding in there too so any
like monetary gift that we were
received for the wedding we threw right
there so thank you
so you didn't get the super juicer
yeah we got a few of those but oh you
did a lot of them okay
so you sold them sounds like you sold
them no we didn't sell any of our
wedding gifts
by the way it's just a joke but thank
you for clarifying we don't want to
upset anybody in their registry
no not a good idea so what was the what
was the moment when you said okay we're
going to do this as a young couple
well when i was a kid my nana sue gave
me the
dave ramsey kids yeah coming through in
the club
and i actually i had all the envelopes
that giving saving and spending even
when we got married
so but i remember after we got engaged
we started doing some counseling and
i kind of told sutton he had some
student loans and
i said those really scare me you know
they're saying it's going to take 15
years to pay them back and that's
a really big commitment and so he said
okay you know i'll do some research she
found some dave ramsey videos we're like
okay we might be able to do that you
know sooner than 15 years and then
over quarantine when there was a sale on
a financial peace university
we did that and i just remember we got
to that last lesson talking about how
you know you do all this so you can be
radically generous and just do what you
know the bible calls us to do
and we kind of sat there and thought
well we want to be those people you know
who can just give someone a car
or just say oh yeah we're going to pay
off your college tuition and so
wow yeah just having that in mind we
decided this isn't going to be you know
10 or 5 years but we want to just get
this done this year
let's knock it out yeah so that was our
motivation yes
that's awesome yeah so how walk somebody
through
you get married people hand you cash
yeah yeah and they smile and twinkle and
they say you will never be able to just
throw money away this is what this
money's for
and you two folks decide to pay off debt
yeah walk us through how that felt
it is painful at first because there are
those shiny new golf clubs shiny new
guitars all these things that i would
love to own
yes yes but i can one day as long as we
are super intentional right now for
those of you listening and not watching
i just i just saw pain shoot through him
as he paused
yes right but i'm the opposite so even
he's a spender i'm a saver so on the
flip side i wouldn't even
want to use the money with the debt for
the first baby step i mean i
like draining the savings down to a
thousand that freaked you out that's my
worst nightmare yeah
so on the fly even if you're not a
spender i mean i still was like
we can't just spend our savings on you
know the loans so even that was
and that's where people thought we were
crazy too going down to that thousand
dollars but if we hadn't done that we'd
still be in debt right now so so what
was the debt student loans what it was
pretty much all student loans but
that shiny thing on her finger
i'm glad we did it she's definitely
worth it but hey
to all the guys out there isn't it
romantic buying a nice ring
that your then new wife has to help pay
off right that just feels gross right
i had it paid up before we got married
sure that was good okay all right
so um walk us through this moment you
came to him
he came to you you both said we're in
yes
yeah walk us through that like who
started that conversation
and i want to paint i'm painting a
picture here for couples who are like i
don't want to i don't know how to
it's kind of when was the moment you
said this is it we're doing this
yeah madison as she said she was
concerned about the debt i was
okay to spending 150 bucks a month for
10 years doing it because it wouldn't i
didn't feel like it would have
inconvenienced us that much
but when she kind of laid out the plan
the goals for us that we wanted to be
radically generous we got to do it
differently to get there
so we just decided hey let's get this
all done
yeah and i'd say yeah on a similar note
it
can seem sometimes logical for instance
i mean we're thinking oh we'll just keep
paying you know those minimum payments
we can do that
in how we'll still be able you know to
be generous we can still give but
just through painted off so fast i mean
now we don't even
we're just able to do so much more with
our finances and just knowing that we'll
never be back in that place
it just gives you the freedom to do
whatever you want yeah we're done
well i gotta ask john really quick i
gotta ask what are you dreaming about is
there a specific
radical generosity even if it's somewhat
small
uh in this in this frame of of life
right now because when you
you talk about that as your motivation
that gives me goosebumps all over
how do you want to be radically generous
i mean this is i've
obviously mentioned those two examples
those are in the videos if you don't do
dave ramsey but
so obviously that would be the end goal
but i mean even now i know one thing is
we've talked about just when you're at
coffee or dinner with a friend just
saying oh i can grab that
which is something i mean again we both
said before this we thought oh we're
really generous but that's something
neither of us would probably ever do
like oh i'll just grab your
10 dinner so and that's also just such a
great way to be a blessing to someone
because when you start doing that
it's just crazy how you think it's so
small but someone's reaction is like oh
you're
gonna pay for my dinner and yeah yeah so
let me tell you what's gonna happen and
this is really to our entire audience
when you have a mind for that
and then you have the freedom to do it
and again you know radical will change
in numbers as you keep saving money you
guys keep living this way
but what you're going to find is is
people are going to present themselves
to you
people you didn't see before are going
to pop right in front of and you're
going to know
right there i got to do that i'm
supposed to help them you watch you
watch it and you do with a smile so who
are your biggest cheerleaders
yeah well i mean obviously both of our
parents his parents are here today
um and my parents and they in our
extended family
have just been such a great example to
us of what it means to be generous and
also being really disciplined with your
finances and also in a weird way we a
lot of them knew we were doing
the ramsay plan but we didn't really
tell them or they didn't know how
intense so i think they were all kind of
a little shocked when we just came one
day we're like oh yeah we paid that all
off but yeah we're done
so what would you tell people the number
one key to getting that debt is
so if you're married you and your spouse
have to be on the same page you have
your big goal that you're trying to
achieve
and after we did that the other things
in our marriage that could have caused
conflicts
it kind of all worked itself out because
we are working on the same team we're
aligned in our goals and we're just
trying to accomplish
the same stuff yeah and i'd say that i
mean it is a sacrifice
and it is painful and it depending on
your circumstance could be so painful
but
it's in the grand scheme of your life
that's just so short
for the rest of your life you're going
to be free and you're going to be
blessed
and i know that i mean the lord has
blessed us in this journey and
in turn you can be a blessing to other
people and when you have that in the end
goal in mind i mean you can do anything
and you're going to get there sutton and
madison paid off
thousand two hundred dollars in nine
months in five days making forty three
thousand to fifty four
thousand dollars count them down
three two one we're debt free
oh that's so cool look at that
they got the champion pose the
interlocked hands
hands above the shoulders we did it and
they did it
so good and to think
i just i can't imagine being a newlywed
and thinking let's get out of depth
not so we can add seven more bedrooms
and four bathrooms
let's get out of debt so we can just
give like crazy yeah yeah
let's go through a journey together so
that we can learn how to talk to one
another and communicate together and
hold each other accountable and have
hard conversations yeah
so that when hard conversation after
heart conversation comes up over the
next 20 30 40 50 years
we're ready for it what a great couple
what a great great future and you watch
you watch
god will bring so much increase to them
because he knows he's
they're going to give it away you watch
kansas city
we're proud of you thank you so much for
sharing your journey this is the ramsay
show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
triple eight eight two five five two two
five this is the ramsay show i'm john
deloni joined here by ken coleman
ever asked questions like how much
should i be saving or how do i pay off
debt even
faster or even what's the right way to
invest
here's the good news you don't have to
figure out the answers on your own
ramsay plus will guide you every step of
the way with a ramsey plus membership
you get all the digital teaching you
need to
really understand money so you can be
confident
you're always doing the right next thing
plus the budgeting app tools and guided
action steps to help you make progress
on your money goals
fast that means no more debt cash in the
bank for emergencies
because not if but when emergencies
happen
and a real plan for your future ramsay
plus helps you get small
consistent wins every day that lead to
big results and lifelong habits
get started today with a free trial at
daveramsey.com
that's dave ramsey.com let's go to dan
in boise idaho dan what's going on
hey guys thanks for taking my call i
just got a quick question for you about
a job change
my wife had fantastic what's up
well um she got pushed out of her long
time
stable job under the guise of
reorganization
and so luckily we've done well enough or
financially it's not going to hit us
real hard
and she right away started looking for
new work
and got offered a job and then
she accepted that job and then a week
later she got offered a different job
that pays
more than she was making at her old job
and
we're just i'm not sure i don't want to
push her in any direction whatsoever
but i just you know i'm not sure how to
handle
like which one should she take you know
or well let's start with what she wants
what does she want to do right now well
well and i am totally cool with whatever
she wants to do don't get me wrong
um and she wants to um take a step back
you know she had a very um
time-intensive job where she worked
60-80 hours a week in certain
certain months of the year and she wants
to
take a step back work part-time which
i'm fine with
and and you know get our benefits that
way
and um i just look into the future you
know i don't want to work forever you
know okay but hold on hold on
i understand what you're telling me but
i'm just simply trying to understand she
just took one job
she's in that job right now she got
offered another job and you're trying to
say which
what which one should she take i've got
an opinion but it's based on what you
tell me
and so i want to know does she want is
she herself right now leaning towards
this new opportunity
that just came along or are you seeing
dollar signs as her husband
and you're trying to go hey let's do
this check out this shiny toy
yeah so where is she where is she
she she wants to follow through with a
part-time job which is totally fine
is that the one she's in right now
that's the one she's in her she's
she just did the orientation for today
got it so if she if she were to take the
one that just got offered
that's back into the full-time deal and
she doesn't want to do that
correct not right now so i think it's
pretty i think it's i think it's pretty
straightforward
if my wife is in this situation i know
that i probably want the more money
myself but if i'm talking to stacey and
i'm going stace what do you want to do
babe
she's going man you know what i've been
doing this 60 hours every seasonal for
once
you know for a long time and i'd like to
just start to step back
i got a good part-time job right now
this is what i want and i've got it i
want to stay put
sounds like that's the right decision
yeah and that's you know that's what i
thought too it's just you know you got
that shiny number out there
that i'm just like well we could really
get ahead
or you know but i understand she wants
to take a step back that's fine
then that's what i got that's what
that's what i would go with
man and i i i would how long you been
married
13 years 13 years um
let me ask something john i'm sorry to
interrupt but but i want to make sure i
didn't ask you this
uh dan what does get ahead mean is that
pay off debt or is it just savings in
retirement what does that mean get ahead
it's a it's a little bit of both you
know i i've been listening to the
program for a while and i really want to
get
debt free and we have been working
towards that goal
but she has her idea of the way she
wants to do it and i have my
you know your guys idea or dave's idea
oh okay so that's what i was making
a little different you guys have there's
something else going on here man
um
the question you asked is not the
question you should have asked yeah what
tell us what's going on in your marriage
man it sounds like there's a
a a fracture there well i wouldn't say
it's a fracture
i just it's hard for me to i don't know
if it's um
you know just explain how this would all
work out if we just went
this direction versus what she wants to
she's a favor
and we have quite a bit in savings we
probably have enough in savings to pay
off the debt that we
that i want to pay off right but she
doesn't want to go down
you know she doesn't want to get rid of
that safety net and
which i get how much debt do you have
but
um total we have about i'd say
45. how much do you have in savings
we uh well okay the debt that i wanted
to pay off so we have about
25 in savings what do you mean the debt
you want to pay off
there's some debt you just like to hold
on to for a long time because you've got
a great relationship with it no no you
realize what show you're going to
clarify here
yeah please i know i know i know stupid
question um
so i have a student loan that i
refinanced and i want to get rid of that
and we have a heloc that we're done with
that we that i want to pay off because
that has a chance for the rate to change
okay what's your total debt give me stop
giving me all the conditions what's your
total debt debt you want in debt you
don't want 45
okay so you did give me the whole number
okay and then you have 25
in savings okay how big of a hit did she
take
just give me a ballpark idea how much
she how much of a hit she took
financially
by going from uh full-time to part-time
oh she probably she's probably gonna
make a third of what she would
okay why is she why is she fried man
um part of it was the atmosphere that
she was in
uh very male dominated kind of you know
toxic you know that kind of deal and it
just
the the place where she was working for
23 years it started out as a family
situation and now it's just gone
straight corporate
you know very different atmosphere and
she's just kind of
done with that whole you know that whole
organization
so when you say hey dan when you sit
down and talk to her
and say hey we've got this 45 000 bucks
there's a proven plan six million people
what is her response
what is it about the way you present
this that makes her think i'm out
um she just wants to have the money in
savings in case something happens
and i and i've framed it like well
something can happen all the time
right that doesn't really matter so you
know here's what i'm going to tell you
when you called the show you talked
about
you don't want to have to work forever
you talked about
yeah you don't want to her to turn this
money down
you want two guys on the radio to tell
your wife what she should be doing
you want to pay off your student loan
and so here's what i want to challenge
you with
you gave me a lot of what you want to do
and with within three or four minutes
it sounds like your wife has come from a
very
toxic to use your words male dominated
world didn't listen to her that was
telling her what to do
and i'm wondering if she's getting that
from you too and i'd love to see you sit
down and say
not hey you know what we could be doing
because what you're doing there is
giving information
you're giving an answer to a question
she really hasn't even asked yet right
and right now she's defaulting to safety
i want you to sit down and say not that
kind of that conversation but
what do we want to do two years three
years
five years you're fraud i love the fact
that you
found this cool opportunity it's going
to cost us a lot of money to us
not you not me but us what do we want to
do and where we want to move
towards what do we want to move forward
towards and i want you to give her an
environment where she can
dream openly because my guess is you
love her so much that you want to give
her the right information and a lot of
times
we can drown our the people that we love
with the right answers and more
information
and really they just want to be heard
they just want to know that things are
safe
and so they default to savings accounts
or jobs or other things to try to grab
safety
i want you to reach out and connect with
her man thank you so much for that call
dan
ken another hour in the books james
zack you guys are both handsome and
professionals
doing a great job this is the ramsay
[Music]
show
[Music]
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show you can listen to all our
shows with the ramsay network app on
your smartphone
browse by topic or even sync clips to
your friends
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio
this is the ramsey show where america
hangs out to have a conversation
about your life your work your money
and your purpose i am john dolone joined
here with best-selling author ken
coleman and we are taking your calls on
pretty much anything
triple eight eight two five five two two
five again how are things going on in
your world
well i gotta tell you john we are having
a blast getting
ready for what i think is gonna be a
massive
job boom i am very very expectant
yes and that is because we see
unemployment numbers getting a little
bit better but more importantly we see
as more and more states begin to open up
states that have been under a pretty
strict lockdown
we're going to see the industry that was
really the hardest hit
because of covid and that was really the
what i would call the hospitality
industry so that's hotels bars
restaurants
amusement parks any kind of touristy
type thing and as we see those
uh sites and types of businesses come
back on board
i think you're going to see a lot of
spike in employment i also think because
a lot of people are sitting
and kind of hunkering down i shared this
last week on the ken coleman show
a lot of people hunkering down kind of
going wait a second maybe a lot of
people that are working on their baby
steps john they're going hey
i want to make a move i feel like now's
the right time to make a move
uh but i'm not ready i don't want to see
how this economy
kind of shakes out so all that said john
we're super excited
uh with what we're doing here at ramsey
solution to help people get hired
and uh i know that you're excited
because you came out with a book that i
think
we call it a ramsey quicker the bottom
line is it's a small book kind of book
that i like
that's a pamphlet right get it to me
baby give me for my buddies that i grew
up with where's the beef one of my
favorite old wendy's commercials right
oh where's the beef yeah the little lady
rolls up where's that baby
and you did this redefining anxiety i
mean that's a pretty bold title
yeah man it was a it actually was a
throwaway line here
um we kept getting calls on with with on
the show about
how to deal with this how do i deal with
this how do i stop this
and it was just a throwaway line man
anxiety is not the problem
our lives are right these lives that
we've been told are well the book has
hit a nerf
it has man and um i think we projected
to sell about 72 copies and
we have sold tens and tens and tens of
thousands so it's been it's been a fun
trajectory man
johndeloni.com d-e-l-o-n-y i want to
make sure you folks know about this
resource because it is
an 80-page read and it's going to give
you a tremendous amount
of practical wisdom but it's really
going to give you hope
and you can you can read it and
immediately begin that's the big thing
man is
yeah man you do not have to be you know
crippled and burdened by this
so we're taking calls hey are you
dealing with some anxiety at work
john and i'll tag team that one right
there together
uh we'll take on what's going on in the
work situation what are your options are
john i'll talk to you about how to
really deal with that difficult
relationships
toxic workplace huge reason for a lot of
unhappiness
some of you struggling financially going
hey i've heard about the show i've just
been listening i don't know where to
start
i'm on board my spouse is on board uh oh
that's a john doloni special we got a
money issue but it's really a
relationship issue so
here's the point we're here we're a
toll-free number
away from clarity and confidence to move
forward that's right triple eight eight
two five
five two two five let's go out to
garrett in
amarillo texas amarillo by afternoon
garrett how are we doing
doing well how are you good good good
what's up brother how can we help
okay so for context my wife and i are on
baby step
two uh we started in the start of 2020
and we have paid off up into this point
fifty thousand dollars
way to go dude student loans uh and
a car way to go brother is right around
twenty one thousand
uh and in savings at this moment uh we
have
just under 20 000 uh because we're in
store mode with a baby coming next month
okay is this your first baby um it is
yeah okay
uh so my question is by the time we get
there
with what is going on in congress which
i don't expect them to do anything good
but if it uh if there is a chance wait
wait what garrett
what why so cynical if there's a chance
of being forgiven
should we let them have the chance of
paying it off and pay for these medical
bills that will be coming from the baby
instead of paying it off up front does
that make sense
yeah absolutely so what's your baby dude
garrett april 25th
girl or boy girl uh-oh first one
yeah first one yeah brother
congratulations man
yeah that's awesome and john and i are
both girl dads and i got to tell you
it's pretty awesome
you you think you understand what's in
your heart garrett you have
no idea there you are going to have a
capacity for love that you
did not know was available your west
texas buddies are going to be laughing
at you
because you're going to want to sit at
home and hug a
tiny little daughter instead of hanging
out like you used to
um here's the thing man it's april it's
into april's when your baby's due i
would hang on to that money
um it's not going anywhere and it has
nothing to do with congress man i
i don't trust that situation as far as i
can throw it or see it or every click's
gonna tell you something different so i
would move that off to the side i
wouldn't even think about that
you've got way more important things to
think about which is the arrival of your
baby girl
you guys are basically sitting on being
debt free but i want you to pile up that
cash
for another couple of months get through
this season
make sure every it's gonna be but make
sure everything's smooth you guys and
don't spin this on
a new bassinet don't get anything fancy
keep living the way you're living but
hang on to that cash and then
man you get into may get into june and
everything's good
go ahead and be debt-free so your little
baby girl has
no idea what that type of stress looks
like hey garrett i understand why you
called and why you asked this question
it's your first baby and you guys don't
even know what you don't know
welcome to parenthood by the way that
never changes i've got three teenagers
right now and i'm reminded every second
of every day that i don't know
what i don't know but one exercise that
i would like you to at least play out
on paper is are you guys do you have
health care so the baby
most of the expenses are through health
care or no
we do our max out of pocket is 4 000
okay and so i was wondering if we need
to just pay that 4 000 out instead of
uh putting it like and adding i'm sorry
i
putting on student loans instead of uh
paying the hospital bills and adding
that to the debt snowball so we're
getting rid of student loans completely
instead of hospital bills does that make
sense yeah no no pay your pay your bills
as they come pay the bill so that's
so this is the exercise right here so we
know you're going to have max out of
pocket 4 000 just for the delivery
in the hospital right assuming
everything goes smoothly so there's 4
000
okay and you said you have 21 set aside
is that right
just under 20 uh set aside and 21 remain
i'm sorry got it so
so let's just call it 19 and change so
almost 20. so you got the four out of
pocket and then i want you to
to talk to some young couples in the
area you guys know some young couples
they got babies yeah get an idea from
them what they spent on diapers
over the last two three months they'll
tell you a million dollars yeah well
it's really not that much
and then and then baby food and whatever
else i want you guys to really play this
out because you've been walking the baby
steps so you're used to writing stuff
down
i just want you to be aware right now
what the increase in cost is going to be
ballpark the budget impact budget budget
because i think you'll
you'd be surprised but we are okay and
we tell folks this
pause the baby steps as you get into
baby but once you get that budget reset
you pay cash for that out of pocket
expense of the hospital and baby's
beautiful and she's at home
then i would really aggressively return
and pay off a big
chunk that's right of those remaining
loans you guys are almost there so do
your homework first you're not going to
need all that money
just because baby's coming i promise and
garrett stop by the flower shop on the
way
and make sure you're the first man to
buy that little girl flowers
great advice john making everybody cry
right now nope just making sure that
girl knows
that's right who lives i agree man i
agree awesome time for you guys
this is the ramsay show
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's
special savings
[Music]
triple eight eight two five five two two
five this is the ramsey show
let's go on out to medford oregon and
talk to travis travis what's going
on hey how you doing thanks for taking
my call
you bet thanks for calling how can we
help
well i'm recently engaged to my fiance
chelsea
congratulations thank you guys
and um she's actually hopefully going to
get on this call here but um
anyway we had a question trying to
navigate how to
combine finances um we're both on the
same page as far as combining our money
together okay
um i am self-employed and
the business requires a substantial
amount of money that kind of stays
within the business and i've been paying
myself out of that
previously and we're just trying to
figure out how the best way to
decide how much i mean do we pay
ourselves
on the personal side just trying to
figure out how to combine finances
um but keeping the business what it
needs
if that makes sense uh kind of it's kind
of a confusing way to ask it you
do you both work for the business or
just you uh just me she has a job
okay and so what do you pay yourself or
how do you pay yourself from your
business
uh basically what i've been doing up
until
uh until now is i pay myself twenty four
hundred dollars a month out of the
business to take care of
a home mortgage you know this the
personal finances
so would you is there any reason why you
would change that number that you've
been paying yourself
the the small amount of discussion that
we've had is we'd like to
basically figure out what we need
together for budget wise
and then if that number needs to change
it can we just we don't have a number in
mind but it's
is that a good way to even look at it
yeah sure i think you're just
overthinking it well
i'm missing something i mean here's the
deal she's gonna have a job yes or no
yes and you have a job and so you pay
yourself in your job
so you guys just sit down and do your
budget what do we think i mean
are you going to be moving into your
house is she going to move into your
house i mean what are we doing there do
we know
uh we actually live together now um
so we're living in a house that i bought
years ago okay so just do the numbers
just do the numbers what is your budget
and now you have you've gone from one
income
to two incomes she's got some bills
maybe
but you guys combine everything yes you
should combine finances
and so you just do a budget and our
combined finances and if all of a sudden
let's say
for whatever reason i'm just doing this
for example purposes
let's say that uh she makes enough money
to where you only have to pay yourself
two thousand bucks a month
well that's 400 bucks a month that's
savings for your company
don't overthink it and then vice versa
if the companies that
shed down some more money to make things
happen for each other then
go the other way too sure you're in
charge it sounds like yeah you're giving
yourself a raise right
but are you
let me say it this way you all need to
have a combined personal income but you
need to have your business expenses
separate from your personal income
yes does that make sense and so can your
business afford your 24 000
year salary
um it can and it probably could afford
some more but the more i take
out of the business side the because
it's we've only been in business for
like four years so
we're in growth mode yeah great so only
pay yourself what you need yeah again uh
i love the question but uh but this is
pretty simple stuff
put your budget together and again if
you could pay yourself less
pay yourself less if you need to pay
yourself more pay yourself more but
get on the same page uh he you said at
the start of the phone call that they're
on the same
page he said they're on the same page so
walk the baby steps out together
right and don't live out of your it
sounds like you may be using your
business account as almost like a flex
spending account for your personal life
you pay your bills but if you need
something you'll just go grab it out
there
man you need to get on a budget on your
business
paying you your salary and then you need
to learn to live off that salary and you
need to ask yourself for a raise if you
need more money but don't be dipping
into your business just for when
when personal things show up that way
that's a good way to get yourself into
some trouble there all right let's go to
edwin
in greensboro edwin what's going on
hi can you hear me yes we can how are
you
good how are you uh so my name's edwin i
live in north carolina
i work as an equipment engineer i'm 22
and i just graduated
last may congratulations my question
thank you my question is what are the
next steps should i get a house
should i continue uh renting i don't
like just money going
to waste my lease ends in september but
the house work is pretty high right now
i save about two thousand dollars each
month
for a house or i don't know what yet and
those ones you can help me out
see if i should look into getting a
house now or not i have about five
thousand dollars in savings
do you have any debts yes twenty
thousand dollars
for student loans and yeah so
what you want to do here is you you
don't have any business buying a house
until you are ready to buy a house and
if you are 20
000 plus dollars in student loan debt
you need to get that paid off first
so what you need to do is you need to
take a thousand dollars and put it
this is a last ditch emergency fund this
is because the moment you get on this
track brother you're you're gonna need
to replace a tire or something like that
you want a thousand dollars
all the rest of your money is gonna go
to pay off those student loans
and you're gonna keep you're going to
keep renting and you're not going to see
the inside of a restaurant and you're
going to rice and beans and you're going
to deliver uber on the weekends
and you are going to knock out that
student i mean
that student loan the rest of that 20
000 worth of debt
you're not going to buy a new car you're
not going to go party you're just going
to
do whatever you got to do to get out of
debt and then
you're going to save up three months
maybe four or five months
worth of emergency expenses you're going
to become your own bank
you're not trying to invest this money
you're not trying to get rich off this
money
this is just money that's going to
protect you from whatever's coming your
way
and one thing you can count on now that
you've graduated college life is going
to be about things coming your way
then you can get on track to start
saving for a house
so you're a couple years away it's no
rush i know it feels like the end of
like i gotta get this done i gotta get
this done
here's the thing man i just bought a
house i've been renting
we got it inspected it was great and
within the first four months i've had to
replace the driveway a new roof
and that stuff's expensive and thank
goodness we had a
an emergency fund to pay for those
things out of that fund
we want your home to be a blessing to
you you want your home to be something
that makes you go
ah not something that you are stressing
about every single week to try to pay
off yep
you got this young man slow down you're
good you're not wasting by renting
you're not wasting tripping you free
that's right
um man i did you feel that
that that burn to buy a house i didn't
have that when i graduated college
no as a matter of fact uh you know well
i when i got out i was working so i was
i was in politics i was working all over
the place so i was in these
i would call mid to crappy level hotels
and i was just working working working
and saving money and then i met stacy
and we got married
and um we rented an apartment and i got
to tell you we thought this apartment
was the taj mahal uh it was a two
bedroom apartment in richmond virginia
yeah
brand new no one had even lived in wow
that is the taj mahal
oh and listen i had been literally all
around the commonwealth of virginia and
really
you know i'm not kidding when i say mid
to crappy level like a mid level would
have been
you know it would have been a shock they
left the light on for you essentially
yeah
and so for me at that stage of my life
being 23
this was like this is a brand new
apartment it was like a giant hotel
suite
and for my wife stacy again she'd been
in college and grad school so it always
shared
every room with two or three other gals
you know in
she had her own room on this one yeah we
had we had like a
a master bedroom with a bathroom and
again a nice size apartment so for us
we were so in love with this living
arrangement
that the housing thing for us was two or
three years later we rented for about
two three years
because we were scared we didn't want to
take on too much debt and i think these
young people got to realize listen
you what you think is throwing away your
money is keeping you free because once
you get locked into debt
that you can't afford let me tell you
something that's a different ball game
uh renting is not a sin we say that a
lot we need to remind you
if you're not ready to purchase a house
with a minimum of 20
down just keep renting you're not
throwing money away no you're protecting
yourself in the short term and in the
long term
i know it feels so good interest rates
are low it feels like this
just slow down ed when you are so far
ahead of the game for even thinking this
way let's get your debt paid off
let's get some cash in your bank you're
going to walk taller you're going to
sleep deeper
and then you can start worrying about
investing
buying a house and start worrying about
what comes next
love your heart brother hang in there
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
blinds.com find out for yourself why
blinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window covering you
get free samples
free shipping and with the new promos
they run every month you'll save
even more use promo code ramsey to get
the best deal
rules and restrictions apply today's
question comes from
jason in bentonville jason asks
how do i get a handle on what my career
sweet spot should be
i have a lot of interest and i'm not
sure which one to pursue well jason
just so happens ken coleman is sitting
next to me and he is the master
at talking about sweet spots and
interest what do you say ken so
what we call the sweet spot is really
your contribution zone and there's
multiple jobs career paths even multiple
dream jobs
in that contribution zone or otherwise
known as the sweet spot so here's how we
figured out you've got a lot of interest
so we want to have a grid by which we
can plug these interests into
and so there's a three-part process or
three parts of the grid if you will
number one is talent
so get down on a piece of paper three
columns far left write the word talent
big bold letters under that i want you
to write down
the hard skills and soft skills your top
five six or seven
if it's 10 that's fine but we want to
know the things that you're really
really good at things that you've always
been able to do very easily things that
people compliment you on
we're just looking for sheer uh talent
proficiency here
second column right passion above that
line
and this is work that you love so i i
define this as
high emotion high devotion
high emotion means when i think about
this work
i get really excited when i'm engaged in
this work i feel the juice
and then i don't want to stop this work
i enjoy doing this work i would do this
work potentially
for free that's high emotion high
devotion
final column on the far right is mission
and this means results that matter
deeply to you results you want to
contribute to the world results you want
to accomplish
so all work creates results john and so
that's why we look at it this way
so now we write down the very specific
type of work under passion and then
under mission
the type of results who are the people
you want to help probably you want to
solve
solutions you want to provide that's
what you're looking for under mission
okay and so once you have those details
you go oh i see
some real clear clues and so we now go
back to
i have a lot of interests what are those
interests
do they line up do you have the talent
to do this interest
do you have the passion to do this
interest does this interest
allow you to align with the results that
you want to put in this world
and so what happens is this is really
stage one of my seven stages
to meaningful work and let's get clear
that's the process so once we know oh
this interest lies
within this sweet spot if you will these
two don't
great because here's what we don't want
to do we don't want to be high on
passion low on talent
that's going to make for some big time
frustration awkward that's that's your
simon cowell moment
there you go but with the reverses we
don't want to be high on talent low on
passion that's going to make for some
desperation right i'm doing this i'm
pretty good at it but i don't have any
juice
so that's why we put it that way and
here's what those answers
plug into really a purpose sentence and
we're talking about purpose in your work
here
you use what you do best to do work you
love
to accomplish results that matter deeply
to you and you will find
that that will open up a whole lot of
work to you it's not just one silver
bullet dream job there's so much out
there so don't get all hung up in that
anxiety of
which path do i choose yeah here's the
reality you could choose any path
as long as it aligns and is within your
sweet spot
tell me if you've heard this because
this has been true in my life
and now that i'm thinking about it out
loud here it matches with some of the
psychology research we are often
terrible at
working through our own thoughts at some
of these things it was a few years ago i
heard an author
i think here in nashville named andrew
peterson said your community often does
a great job of defining your calling
i've often said you know be talking but
to my wife and you know
my mission is this and she'll laugh and
go no it's not
this is what i always see you doing this
is when i see you walk taller this is
what brings you joy
i'm really good at this and she'll say
no you're not
you're really good at this
is it i guess in my life i often
often will have these conversations with
other people like bef when i got offered
this job i called somebody's back in
texas actually went visited with them
and they listened to how preposterous it
sounded that i was going to quit my
other career
to come do this maybe thing on the radio
and they all listened and said yeah that
sounds crazy and that sounds right you
know what i mean
sure because you're good at this you're
sure there's something about for me
having other people reflect this
to me the reason is because
self-awareness as you know being a
psychologist self-awareness is not easy
no um there's so many things it's we
either over-inflate or under-inflate
ourselves right yeah and so when i look
in the mirror and see me
i see imperfections i see stories from
my past i see failures
i see fears i see doubts and it's
literally like you know
trying to drive in a super foggy night i
can only and i can only see
literally two of the windshield maybe to
the hood of the car right when we look
in the mirror and we're dealing with all
those other things sometimes it's very
hard to see ourselves clearly
so having people who are very honest
with us
who know us well right and love us
enough to be honest
and that we can hear that we can hear
that is a game changer because again
it's like them showing us a very clear
mirror and they're going
you think like you just said that you're
not good at this but the fact of the
matter is
you you are good at it well i'm not a
really great speaker
well you're actually really good at
communicating whether you think you're a
great speaker and i see you in front of
people when you do
people light up you know whatever that
is right so yes this process
is good that i lay out is good but i
always teach
go give feedback i love it because you
want somebody to tell you whether or not
you're delusional it's
we make fun of these poor kids on
american idol
or other talent shows that go out there
and proceed to just look like
idiots and morons and just doofuses on
stage because we laugh at them because
we're like oh my gosh
they're passionately awfully performing
and we laugh
and because of the line of work i'm in
it's never funny to me i'm
dying when i see that person do that
because i want to rush up there and grab
them before they start and go
hey you're passionate about this
but you don't have the talent to do it
and in the first four or five seasons
i'll never forget
the most common refrain in my head and
with my buddies was
where what kind of friends yeah or
parents what kind of family
oh somebody's got to sit you down and
say hey yeah well here's my favorite
i mean i got to tell you you you want to
talk about revealing you any of you've
watched american idol before you've seen
the kid who gets told that they're not
good and they get mad at the world-class
judges and producers who've you know
sold to millions of records right and
they're like you i'll show you you don't
get it
american idol's missing out on me and
like they're the ones that are
delusional yeah
and as they're storming off in anger
you almost always see the parent in the
background of the camera shot
and the parent is either doing one or
two things you know they're getting
along with it and they're just like
these people are idiots my son's
talented or my dog whatever
but the ones that i see most is the
parent who's ashamed and in this moment
the parents realizing i should have told
them yep
but they asked me and i fell prey to the
parenting style of we want johnny and
susie to feel good
right instead of teaching them how to be
good
do good and this is the parenting
mistake we make we get so worried about
our kids feeling good we want our kids
to like us instead of teaching them how
to be
good and do good and by the way being
good and doing good
comes with a massive massive massive
dose of self-awareness and boundaries
and
here's the match you can't have
boundaries if you're not aware yeah
it costs your parents have to model it
right yeah because they can't talk all
day to your kids so they like to show
them that's exactly what it is they lie
to their you sing so good johnny
johnny goes out there and and humiliates
himself and the reason he's mad is
because johnny can't process his
feelings because he's been told he's
great this whole time
and then these three people just told
him he's awful
how are you supposed to process that
john or when somebody calls you
at work let's bring this a little bit
closer to home
hey man i got passed over again yeah i
think they don't like me
right you can do one or two things you
can say hey let's go get coffee
yeah and tell them the truth hey man
you're always late yeah or the work you
do
yeah you're better than this yeah you're
unlikable you're not gonna like this job
right right this is a budget job you
like be or
you're kind of a jerk man yeah you act
like a bull in a china shop
or the other response is yeah man
they're just hosing you
it's probably because of filling the
blank it's all them and that doesn't
help anybody because they're
because then they take that attitude and
then they take that toxicity with them
to the next stop and they just
honestly they just dump it on everybody
else everywhere they go because they
never get any truth
which leads to that enlightening
opportunity to go
oh this is where i can succeed
this is where i can have success this
is where i sense significance i can look
back on my life
whether it's kevin roberts or general
thompson or phil schubert i could rattle
things off all day
of folks mike gibson who have stopped me
pulled me in a room and said
this isn't the right path for you you
can do better work here
[Music]
[Music]
today's scripture is ephesians 2 10
for we are god's handiwork created in
christ jesus to do good works
which god prepared in advance for us to
do
walt disney says the way to get started
is to quit talking and begin doing
we gotta do that one again i love me
some wall walt disney says
the way to get started is to quit
talking and begin doing ken
why is it so hard to stop planning and
thinking and
researching and asking and going to
coffee because just go
hit the dude in the mouth and see what
happens because we got fear on one
shoulder and doubt on the other
and fear is going this is going to
happen if you step out this is going to
happen this could happen
and then you got doubt going it's too
late it's going you don't have what it
takes
you're too old you should have got a
different degree you should have fill in
the blank yeah
fear and doubt man it just turns that
amygdala on in our brain dude that
fight or flight and we're like oh and
it's just
you gotta get out of your head and
follow your heart i'm always telling
people that there's a wrestling match
between your head and your heart
and uh you gotta follow your heart you
gotta follow your heart because if your
heart's going
i know this is right we know we need to
do it we've used our head enough we've
logic this thing to death
and we know we have what it takes talent
we know we're passionate about the work
and we know we want to create these
results then go it's something just
go the fighting the fighters training
camp is over i mean
just go see i think sometimes we we make
guys like walt disney this
these magical mythical business heroes
until you actually
learn their story and you read his story
he's only that because the dude straight
up went
after it man all in all in
the boat yeah so you know
grab the story there and you realize
that's what made him
he actually believed nobody else
believed him except his brother
roy he just kept swinging yeah
he got it right the way to get started
is to quit talking
and begin doing i love it man let's go
to hope in roanoke virginia what's up
pope how are we doing
i'm doing great thanks for having me
thank you so much for
your call how can we help
all right so literally as soon as my
husband and i really sat down and
committed to the dave ramsey method
our household income doubled the
following week whoa
you can't just dangle that hope how did
that happen give us the details
well my husband and i both had changes
within our jobs he got a substantial
raise
and i was finally taking off for a low
status
made full-time and given a substantial
raise wow
so when you say double give me give me a
ballpark what's the number
well for the past the first three years
of our marriage the most we brought in
was 45
000 a year this year we're estimated to
bring in about 95.
good for you very cool all right keep
going what's your question
yeah so um
uh i grew up in severe poverty actually
um in fact my family is homeless right
now after their second foreclosure
um so my question
my question is how do i go about
managing my money without feeling
overwhelming guilt over my household
income
and still managing the math amount of
debt that we do have
how much debt do you have let's get that
out of the way first and john i'll talk
you through that guilt stuff
so i'm 65 000.
that's it just just 65. that's it
10 in a card 25 in cards and 30 in
students okay well slow down give that
to me again what
give me the breakdown okay ten thousand
cars
okay 25 000 in cars
like credit cards oh god and then 30 000
in student loans
okay all right how much is that car
worth
my car i paid uh 17 000 for it we have
about
the tennis what's left and we're sharing
a car
okay so y'all are after it so are y'all
just running and gun in here you you've
you essentially had money fall from the
sky right you all been working hard your
income has
doubled and when you went all in you had
a plan
are y'all throwing every extra penny
towards this debt
we uh literally the moment we decided
we've already
switched to the past envelope system we
have a certain amount of money every
paycheck that strictly goes to build we
have a math amount going towards debt
where
i did some math we're estimated to pay
everything off in about two to two and a
half years
okay that's amazing so you just answered
one half of your question
yes and the good news is you answer the
half that i may have weighed in on so
this is all on dr delony now
but that second half of the question was
you said how do i
manage my money and take good care of it
and not feel guilty well look
you're walking out the baby steps you
guys have tremendous momentum
just follow the plan and you guys are
doing it i sense that
that joy in you and you can feel it and
you
see that future i love that you got that
two two and a half year marks here's the
deal
keep walking it out don't stop the baby
steps for nothing
don't stop now that's the answer to that
question
john that guilt thing though yeah that
guilt thing will wear you out so tell me
about growing up what was it like
um so when my family bought their first
house it was worth 190
000 um when they got foreclosed on
it they had 290 000 in equity and it's
only worth about 240.
um so there's a huge history of racking
up credit card and racking up all this
debt
um and in fact there was a mindset in my
household
that get was more
godly and it was really horrible to
witness
growing up and so whenever anyone in my
family had more money
the rest of the family would almost
attack them
and that is what i grew up in and so
now that i have the ability to build
wealth
it's scary yeah
so money money is going to set off money
was weaponized right
and it was absolutely a scarcity right
so you got to see
you had a first row seat to pain
and hurt and people beating each other
up emotionally psychologically possibly
even physically
over this thing called money this thing
called debt
are you getting calls now are you or is
this something that you see
and that you feel this nudge to go
respond to or to go help out
at the same time you know we're not even
in a place to do that
they um i've already have pressure put
on me
to um take in my siblings
um i have an 18 year old autistic
brother and a 13 year old sister
and um it i've had pressure put on me
for helping them find
a home and getting out of their
situation
and my husband very kindly has been
trying to help me to put
boundaries between that right but it
doesn't you know the guilt runs deep
you know and learning when to say no is
extremely difficult when you're dealing
with these kinds of circumstances
no no doubt about it so your husband's
on to something
what does a boundary look like for you
um
here's what i'm not gonna do hope i'm
not gonna tell you here's what you
should do with your
with your siblings the children
i'm not gonna tell you you should not do
this or that or that or this
what i am going to tell you is you've
got to put your oxygen mask on first
you've got to make sure you are you are
financially okay or you're going to just
swamp the whole boat
right you're going to end up in the
exact same situation because
you're trying to save somebody but
you're not anchored in
right hope let me ask you a question
really quick as it sits right this
moment as you're talking to john and i
are you
worried about financial ruin or
relationship you
ruin neither i
neither good because here's the deal if
you
allow the threat of
your family being mad at you
you will end up resenting them and you
go help them and you sink the financial
ship like john's talking about
you're going to cause tension with your
husband you're going to cause tension
with the very people
that you're trying to help because
you'll resent them so i'm so glad you
answered that way
which tells me is this is this really a
guilt
thing or do you just feel badly that you
feel like you're free from this
almost like this free from this mental
lock on the family and you're free of it
i will tell you um i made a personal
decision
the moment my husband and i married um
that the poverty and the drug abuse
and all these cycles that have gone up
for generations were going to end with
me
good for you and good for you
our income doubling in a week yeah
that's a sign hope
it's a sign hope don't look back hold on
to your boundaries hold on to your space
and then when you're okay
you can revisit the support right and if
there is abuse make sure you're calling
the right people to get the
proper authorities involved i want to
say thanks to james
and zach bennett thanks to my good
friend ken coleman and thanks to you
america
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer for
the ramsay show
this episode is over but if you heard
about an event product or service and
didn't have a chance to write it down
don't worry we list everything you've
heard about during this episode in the
podcast show notes section
or head over to daveramsey.com and click
dave recommends
thanks for listening
you